salut robin a tant changé un truc toi
non oui c'est fait une permanente
ouais voilà c'est ça ouais pourquoi du
coup je trouve que ça va mieux
d'ailleurs je comprends pas pourquoi je
suis pas né comme ça à bonne question ça
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va tester un nouveau truc
on est d'accord on se pose tous pleins
de questions genre plein de questions
sur notre santé sur notre corps etc
c'est pour ça que vous êtes là c'est que
je suis là aussi des fois c'est complexe
donc ça mérite une vidéo des fois c'est
plus futiles ou plus légers donc la
réponse elle est beaucoup plus simple et
du coup elle est beaucoup plus rapide
mais est ce que c'est vraiment une
raison pour laisser toutes ces questions
sans réponse et ben moi je dis non
alors aujourd'hui on va tester un
nouveau format on va partir sur quelque
chose de plus court et on va juste
répondre à la simple question de romain
pourquoi j'ai les cheveux raides et pas
les cheveux frisés et ce nouveau format
il s'appelle dans la vie on n'est jamais
content je vous le dis comme je le pense
l'armée c'est vrai regardez les gens qui
ont les cheveux raides
ils sont faire des permanentes et les
gens qui ont les cheveux bouclés ils
sont faire des lissages encore et encore
et encore et oui parce que non seulement
on choisit pas sa nature de cheveux mais
en plus il n'y a aucun moyen de la
changer de façon permanente
alors disons de façon durable
et justement pour comprendre pourquoi on
peut pas changer de façon définitive la
nature de ses cheveux il faut comprendre
pourquoi à la base on a soit les cheveux
raides soit les cheveux frisés et ça
tombe bien parce que c'est justement la
question de romain et la réponse se
trouve sous notre peau dans notre terme
d'abord c'est là que se trouvent les
bulles de capillaires c'est-à-dire là où
naissent nos cheveux puis à travers
notre épiderme dans lequel se trouvent
nos follicules à l'intérieur desquels
les cheveux se développent et pousse
jusqu'à la sortie
c'est une asymétrie à l'intérieur de ces
deux structures qui va déterminer si nos
cheveux vont tous ces raids ondulés
frisés ou crépus
en gros en fonction de l'inclinaison du
bulbe et des différents compartiments du
follicule nos cheveux se développe
différemment si tout est aligné nos
cheveux poussent tout droit donc ils
sont raides mais il se développe pas
droit donc ils sortent frisé si les
structures sont courbés ok mais pourquoi
nos bulbes et nos follicules sont soit
droit soit courbet est passé à 85 voire
95 % héréditaire
et le jeune en cause s'appelle le tch le
tch âge son boulot c'est de coder la
tricot et aline qui est la protéine
principal de la structure de nos
follicules pileux
d'ailleurs le tch âge c'est l'un des
trois gène dont la mutation est en cause
dans une maladie qui s'appelle le
syndrome des cheveux un quoi fable et là
on parle pas de mes trois épis quand je
me lève le matin on parle d'un vrai
syndrome c'est une dysplasie rares du
cuir chevelu
c'est à dire une anomalie de son
développement avec des signes comme des
cheveux qui deviennent progressivement
couleur paille très sec très raide très
souvent dressés sur la tête est
impossible à domestique ça commence dans
l'enfance et ça ça rend généralement
tout seul
en grandissant donc on a compris la
nature de nos cheveux elle dépend de
facteurs génétiques et structurelles
donc des trucs qui sont très
profondément ancré en eux alors du coup
vous savez il ya des gens qui ont les
cheveux bouclés quand ils sont utiles et
qu'ils viennent raid en grandissant pas
tout le monde mais des fois ça arrive
ou l'inversé d'ailleurs des gens qui ont
les cheveux raides boucle en grandissant
mais comment c'est possible
et bien la réponse à ce mystère
c'est que c'est un mystère
il ya plein d'hypothèses différentes
mais rien n'a été démontré avec
certitude les gens qui parlent de
renouvellement des follicules y en a qui
mettent en cause des hormones et y en a
qui partent dans des histoires de chimie
du cheveu ah oui parce que ce qu'on sait
par contre c'est que nos cheveux ont une
structure chimique assez espiègle nos
cheveux ils sont formés de protéines de
kératine qui sont liées entre elles de
différentes façons et la façon dont ces
protéines sont liées entre elles peut
être modifié en fonction du taux
d'hydrogène dans l'air qui modifient
leur structure et donc leur forme mais
de façon temporaire
c'est la raison pour laquelle certaines
personnes ont les cheveux qui frise
quand il pleut ou quand l'air est humide
c'est à dire chargée en hydrogène voit
la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que ce nouveau format vous a
plu dites-nous sable dans les
commentaires comme ça on voit si on
remet ça ou si on laisse tomber d'ici là
je vous en conjure
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]